clark county though has made an online  form available for you  to learn whether you're interested in  getting that medicine the southern  nevada health district plans to give an  update on vaccine clinics this afternoon  that'll be at about one o'clock  a new vaccine distribution system will  divide all of us in nevada into two  lanes there's either front line workers  or the general public now the general  public will get vaccinated mostly at  pharmacies  frontline and essential workers will get  vaccinated at sites like  high schools unlv possibly even allegion  stadium  mega vaccination centers at cashman  center and the convention center are  also being planned  and they should be opened at the end of  the week